[Musica]
grazie grazie molte
Buonasera a tutti
Sono Claudio scardovi amministratore
delegato e fondatore di Hope è un fondo
di investimento alternativo interamente
dedicato
per realizzare investimenti che abbiano
una missione molto Specifica e molto
elevata guidare il paese verso obiettivi
di sostenibilità lo facciamo credendo
molto in un principio di
democratizzazione del capitalismo di
capitalismo per tutte e per tutti che
diano i privade Equity come opportunità
a tutti i sottoscrittori ai cittadini a
residenti anche non ricchi anche non
professionali per perseguire questi
obiettivi di sostenibilità la nostra
sfida è importante è una sfida di Hope
Ma è una sfida credo collettiva del
paese perché mai come in questo momento
è diventato fondamentale critico urgente
riconvertire una quota del risparmio
gestito italiano dei nostri risparmi per
investimenti nell'economia reale Per
ridare competitività attrattività
produttività ma anche sostenibilità non
solamente economica di questo vorrei
parlarvi è una sfida la nostra ma anche
collettiva da fare tremare i polsi
che però alla fine si declina è un
messaggio molto semplice vorremmo
tornare a investire di più è meglio in
Italia come italiani e investire bene
nel paese
per fare questo per vincere questa sfida
quasi impossibile Io credo che sia
opportuno tornare a tre elementi che non
sono tecnici non sono finanziari non
sono matematici ma fanno riferimento a
tre concetti
la fiducia la speranza e poi l'azione
Parto dalla prima la fiducia è
fondamentale tutto parte della fiducia
abbiamo mercati liberi progressisti
perché c'è fiducia abbiamo una società
civile delle Repubbliche democratiche il
progresso la civiltà perché c'è fiducia
nel mio mondo che è il mondo della
finanza tutto è basato sulla fiducia e
sulla credibilità crediamo nel valore
della moneta perché la moneta ci
permette di scambiare beni e servizi
senza ricorrere al barattolo ci permette
di capitalizzare le nostre ricchezze ci
permette di investire al meglio gestendo
il nostro ciclo di investimento
risparmio consumo nostro della famiglia
della società
crediamo anche al valore del credito del
corrispondente debito perché questi ci
permettono come strumenti di trasferire
le risorse scarse dell'economia nel
tempo e nello spazio tra persone che
hanno tanto denaro ma poche idee poca
voglia di fare e altre persone che
invece hanno creatività innovatività
imprenditorialità Ma hanno pochi denari
per farlo questo lo possiamo fare
attraverso anche il ruolo dei mercati
degli intermediari finanziari che
conducono idealmente a un'ottimizzazione
ideale che massimizza la ricchezza
creata nel mondo in maniera sostenibile
Questa è la fiducia nella finanza ma mi
chiedo è giusto chiederci una fiducia
ben riposta è una fiducia mi ha risposto
a quella che ci ha condotto a una
insostenibilità totale economica perché
da un punto di vista del nostro paese
abbiamo creato debito pubblico oggi 2770
miliardi circa il 150% del prodotto
interno lordo
che rappresenta oggi un fardello quasi
insostenibile per l'economia soprattutto
per le nostre figlie per i nostri nipoti
che saranno chiamati a ripagarli questo
debito pubblico è stato peraltro negli
ultimi decenni finanziato anche
attraverso lo stampaggio di moneta
pensate nell'area Euro la moneta è
moltiplicata per 5 negli ultimi 10 anni
nell'area dollaro è moltiplicata per 10
e tutto questo ha condotto a una
inevitabile strutturale inflazione oggi
a circa il 10% che di fatto agisce come
tassa iniqua e subdola attaccando il
potere di acquisto in principio dei più
poveri dei più difesi dei meno preparati
c'è un'insostenibilità economica ma c'è
anche un insostenibilità forse ancora
più grave da un punto di vista sociale
la società e lacerata ci sono guerre
regionali globali Se pensate a livello
globale l'un per cento della popolazione
detiene più del 50% della ricchezza
finanziaria quindi l'economia è molto
ricca ma è anche molto povera perché
oltre un terzo della popolazione globale
vive sotto il livello di povertà
infine anche insostenibilità ambientale
siamo depauperando le risorse scarse
dell'ambiente l'ecosistema che vi viene
equilibrio con l'uomo non è più così in
equilibrio e attraverso la sfida del
cambiamento climatico abbiamo posto un
rischio di natura quasi esistenziale che
dovremo affrontare al meglio al più
presto per garantire non solo un clima
vivibile per noi ma la stessa vivibilità
sostenibilità esistenziale di nuovo
delle generazioni che verranno dopo di
noi ecco tutto questo se questi sono i
fallimenti della finanza pongono un
dubbio la finanza spesso interpretata
come fine non come mezzo è una Finanza
legittima o piuttosto introduce quella
che io chiamo una Nemesi della ricchezza
dove il modello di Finanza che
conosciamo speculativo di breve periodo
ha generato insabilità insostenibilità
ingiustizie
che ricadono come nella classica Nemesi
sulle generazioni future sui millennial
sulla generazione Z sugli Alfa che
verranno sulle nostre figlie sui nostri
nipoti a cui stiamo lasciando debito
pubblico inflazione monete inflativa
guerre
Rotture societarie
una sfida climatica che è difficile da
gestire Ecco se tutto questo è il
contesto della Finanza che oggi ci
troviamo a dover affrontare dobbiamo non
solo cercare di recuperare passo passo a
piccoli pezzettini la fiducia che ci
porta a usare la finanza come mezzo ma
anche pensare oltre recuperare il
secondo elemento che ritengo
fondamentale per avere una prospettiva
che ci guidi verso futuri più alti e più
positivi il secondo elemento
fondamentale è speranza o in inglese che
fa riferimento soprattutto al futuro
traguardiamo un futuro perché chi crede
nel futuro investe maggiormente meglio
nel futuro si dà da fare
cosiddette a produttività quello che sa
fare e conseguentemente a più chance di
avere successo nella vita di raggiungere
benessere di essere felice di
contribuire al contesto complessivo
della società dell'economia
dell'ambiente è una speranza che parte
da valori condivisi che ha una missione
molto alta che ha delle ambizioni molto
Sfidanti e che è guidata ogni giorno
dalle emozioni e dalle passioni che ci
aiutano nella strategia dell'incertezza
di ogni giorno del contesto
economico-politico
domestico e complessivo a prendere
decisioni e comportamenti che idealmente
ci conducono verso un ritorno un
recupero di quella sostenibilità totale
che abbiamo perduto nel tempo
Se questa è la tesi L'enunciato positivo
della Speranza Purtroppo esiste anche un
antitesi di questa e l'antitesi nel
mondo della finanza è ancora legata a
grandi bugie che minano l'impatto della
speranza per condurci ad investire bene
nel paese
la prima grande bugia con il debito
pubblico e con la moneta si risolvono
piccoli e grandi problemi non è vero si
crea inflazione iniquità sociale
insabilità economica e a un certo punto
il modello scoppia seconda grande bugia
conseguentemente Siamo un paese povero
in cui non è opportuno investire
che invecchia e che in qualche modo
rende l'investimento come capitale
proprio poco interessante rispetto ad
altri paesi Infatti l'investimento in
private Equity che quello più redditizio
potenzialmente meno rischioso più
decorrelato è lasciato ai ricchi per
moltiplicare le proprie ricchezze poco
accessibile ai poveri e oggi viene
soprattutto direzionato rispetto ad
altri paesi per aumentare il loro
benessere la loro produttività ma
dimenticandoci di investire nel nostro
paese che invece ha grandi potenzialità
Circa 13 trilioni di asse 3 Ali che
comprendono PMI di eccellenza ma anche
un contesto immobiliare di grande valore
e con grandi potenzialità di ripresa e
Infrastrutture
fisiche e digitali che devono essere
innovate per condurci verso appunto più
alti futuri Ecco tutte queste bugie
questa antitesi della Speranza ci
conduce purtroppo in un vicolo cieco che
io chiamo il trilemma della finanza LSD
è una Finanza d'assalto nel vuoto dove
continuiamo a fare il rollover del
debito pubblico Long Death dove
continuiamo ad emettere moneta creando
inflazione lo facciamo valorizzando il
risparmio della popolazione che
veicoliamo quasi unicamente sui titoli
di Stato sui conti correnti quindi
usiamo quello che tecnicamente si chiama
il Saving slat la sdlsd per fare che
cosa continuare a finanziare deficit
correnti e ricorrenti di uno stato
paternalista e spendaccione che non
investe per aumentare la crescita
potenziale del paese non investe per
aumentare la produttività dell'economia
non investe per aumentare la coesione
sociale e il riequilibrio ambientale
piuttosto investe tipicamente di governo
in governo per gestire un ciclo
elettorale che ci condu
verso futuri che non vorremmo nostri
dunque se la fiducia non è sufficiente
serve la speranza neanche la speranza è
sufficiente e serve un terzo elemento
questo terzo elemento è l'azione
azione che io chiamo energia volitiva
voglia di darsi fare ogni giorno
rimboccandosi le mani cercando di dare
un piccolo contributo con l'azione con
le scelte con i comportamenti anche con
gli investimenti per creare un paese
diverso deve essere anche un'azione
resiliente perché ci saranno
innumerevoli difficoltà rischiosità
vincoli resistenze a questo percorso di
cambiamento del paese quindi dobbiamo
essere resilienti rispetto a quello che
ci attende è un'azione anche come titolo
di proprietà come sapete azione fa
riferimento al titolo di proprietà
attraverso un private Equity Democratico
tutti i potenzialmente Possiamo
diventare azionisti di una piccola fetta
dell'economia reale italiana di oggi e
potenzialmente di una fetta ancora più
importante di quello che è il futuro di
crescita redditività
benessere del paese se saremo capaci di
veicolare i nostri risparmi rispetto a
investimenti che oltre ad obiettivi di
economicità avranno obiettivi anche di
sostenibilità sociale ed ambientale
azione poi Fa anche rima con generazione
generazione vuol dire focalizzarsi su
interventi di rigenerazione urbana per
rendere attrattive le nostre città
recuperare i nostri territori generare
valore nel lungo periodo preoccuparsi
anche dei nostri nipoti delle nostre
figlie che sono la generazione
millennial Z e Alfa che verrà a cui oggi
stiamo di fatto regalando semplicemente
debiti da pagare insostenibilità
problemi da risolvere senza una chiara
via di uscita ecco tutto questo di nuovo
la tesi enunciativa positiva dell'azione
si scontra con un'antitesi che di nuovo
negativa perché Purtroppo viviamo
in quello che molti ricordano il paese
del Gattopardo è un paese del Gattopardo
in qualche modo legato e consegnato a
una decadenza ineluttabile in cui il
cambiamento apparentemente è impossibile
dove i tanti principi di Salina ogni
giorno si affaccenano per cambiare le
cose perché alla fine nulla cambi
veramente siamo destinati all'inazione
siamo destinati al fatalismo o un futuro
migliore è possibile
Ecco credo che la mia sfida personale
che è piccola cosa la sfida di Hope che
è una cosa un pochino più grande la
sfida collettiva è rigettare le grandi
bugie rigettare nei mesi della ricchezza
rigettare quello che il fallimento della
finanza e LSD rigettare anche il paese
del Gattopardo per puntare a cambiare le
cose riprendendoci in mano il nostro
destino imparando a investire meglio
nell'economia reale del paese non
solamente per diventare milioni
investitori ma anche attraverso l'atto
di essere azionisti del paese migliori
consumatori migliori lavoratori quindi
migliori cittadini in sintesi per noi La
grande sfida investire bene in Italia è
una sintesi estrema che richiama una
sfida quasi epocale dobbiamo
collettivamente tornare a investire nel
paese non solamente per fare bene in
termini economici e finanziari per
requisito sicuramente importante ma
anche per perseguire obiettivi dove il b
grande del bene comune sono importanti
strategici prioritari e ci garantiscono
un futuro che è degno di questo nome un
futuro che siamo diventeremo orgogliosi
di consegnare i nostri figli ai nostri
nipoti e dove anche il valore della
finanza come mezzo e non come fine può
essere recuperato e ha servito a un
obiettivo superiore dove recuperiamo in
qualche modo l'insostenibile leggerezza
consegnata alla insostenibilità
economica sociale e ambientale per
creare valore benessere per noi
e per le generazioni future qui concludo
è stato un intervento breve ma volevo
consegnarvi questi importanti messaggi
questo importante sfida Io credo che i
cambiamenti in Italia è possibile
investire bene in Italia è possibile
urgente e richiesto e che dopo possiamo
farlo collettivamente recuperando la
fiducia la speranza e l'azione Grazie
[Applauso]